today I'm going to talk about the
ketogenic diet intermittent fasting your
thyroid and your hair sometimes when
people go on keto and they do in a min
fasting they may notice a loss of hair
and they start getting cold some people
might even see an enlarged thyroid gland
so there is a way to do it correctly
without having to lose your hair or have
a thyroid problem so let's take a look
at a couple things
vitamin A activates the thyroid
receptors okay in the thyroid gland
itself so the pituitary gland which is a
tiny little gland in your brain sends a
hormone down to the thyroid and it
controls the thyroid and this hormone is
called thyroid stimulating hormone
connects to the thyroid little receptor
and it has several functions one is that
it increases the size of the thyroid
hormone number two it increases the
production of the thyroid hormones like
t4 so low amounts of vitamin A inhibit
the receptors so you're not activating
the receptors of the thyroid very much
so what's gonna happen is if you don't
have this activation the receptors this
hormone is going to start going higher
and higher and higher to try to connect
to make the thyroid work because there's
also a feedback loop telling the
pituitary what to do so if we're not
getting this feedback loop because it's
not connecting the pituitary we'll start
to increase this hormone right here one
of the problems with that is that this
thyroid can then start to enlarge okay
so it starts getting bigger but because
it's not connecting that well you may
not have the quantity of thyroid
hormones if you look in the mirror you
can kind of see if it's kind of swollen
right there and then you also have a
decreased uptake of this hormone and
this could be one of the reasons where
you're cold
there's other reasons too that don't
involve the thyroid gland now the
thyroid gland is not working correctly
one of the symptoms that you can
experience is hair loss okay so you can
it be cold hair loss and large
now the next question is could you be
deficient in vitamin A or not let's take
a look at that
vitamin A comes from certain foods like
eating liver egg yolks butter fish oils
as in cod liver oil and even certain
leafy greens that can be converted into
the active form of vitamin A realize
that the greens contain carotenoids
which is the precursor for retinol and
the other thing you need to know is that
the conversion is really like 10% under
certain conditions so you're not going
to make a lot of active vitamin A from
consuming a lot of greens the other
thing you should know is that you may
not be able to absorb vitamin A properly
if you have a fatty liver or you have
cirrhosis of the liver or an inflamed
liver or you have a gallbladder problem
or we have a missing gallbladder or you
don't have enough bile because you need
bile to absorb this fat soluble vitamin
these are just reasons why you may show
a problem with a vitamin A deficiency
because you're eating these but they're
not being absorbed correctly now if you
have gastric bypass for example that
could be another reason why you don't
absorb vitamin A because you have a now
shortened small intestine also if you
have celiac or scar tissue in your colon
or SIBO which is small intestinal
bacterial overgrowth pretty much
anything going on with the small
intestine could create a vitamin A
deficiency another symptom that you may
notice with vitamin A deficiency is a
lack of vision at night when you're
driving so that's another little symptom
the other problem with vitamin E
absorption is a lack of zinc and a lack
of zinc is way more common than in
vitamin A deficiency why because we
don't store zinc very effectively if
you're not actively consuming zinc on a
regular basis you're going to be
deficient zinc is needed to transport
vitamin A in to the thyroid zinc is also
needed in the production of thyroid
hormone as well as the conversion of
t4 to t3 so this is another really
important trace mineral and on top of
that if you're consuming no animal
products let's say you're vegan or
you're consuming grains that's another
way to become zinc deficient some of the
best foods that have good amounts of
zinc shellfish fish in general and red
meat there's other foods but you're
gonna get a lot of zinc from these foods
the other problem with zinc is if you
have an intestinal problem or a liver
problem that could be another reason why
you're not absorbing zinc so this goes
beyond just the diet let's say that you
have a problem with the small intestine
because you have a history of
antibiotics you can take more of zinc
and then that way you have enough
because if it's not being absorbed you
can just take more and that just might
give you what you need to offer this
conversion the other problem is maybe
you're not consuming enough shellfish or
red meat or you're not having any of
these well then you can just eat more of
the raw materials if you want more
information about the thyroid gland
check out this video right here